he was a Defensive Rookie of the month
of September that's how the second round
pick out of South Carolina State came
out of the gate and he's right here on
the Rich Eisen show how are you Darius
I'm blessed for having you on the show
how about that right back at you how is
this game come to you so well so far do
you think in the NFL
Darius oh my oh my deepest water just
playing well trying to China keeping me
clean and jazz Dana Anthony Walker and
he's making it a whole lot easier for me
making a lot of chicks and they play so
I can place pass and doing all walk
through we're all with Coach F loose so
I don't see maybe 20 to 30 times in them
and practice or walkthrough so we are
getting the game is easier for me to
react to this I know that's very nice
you to talk about your teammates and
your coaches but there is an eye on
Darius and you were miked up this week
sir and you seem like you are built to
play this game you're long and tall and
just in terms of what you are is a
linebacker in stature but man you you
have some serious giddyup going on what
makes you built to win to play this game
and winning it Terrace just growing up
growing up not really having too much it
kind of just working for absolutely
everything and I always played with a
chip now my shoulders been overlooked in
college and then any high school and
then going to college just having that
same chip and after every game I want to
have the most high schools I want to be
a player with everything so I just go
out and just compete every single play
as is my last play and just hopefully at
the end of the game I know that I put it
all on the line and hopefully there we
come out with a victory let me dive into
that a little bit more what do you mean
you say you didn't have much growing up
tell me about it my mom Eric is school
mom raising raising our kids I had to
buckle customary I had one brother
passed away so it was kind of rough
growing up then had all the clothes all
the stuff that I wanted but I had almost
everything I need but just having to
work earlier I got my first job when I
was 13 working at the restaurant washing
dishes so I mean I just got to do
absolutely everything to get kind of
what I wanted so I mean I knew like
right then that I had to work and
nothing was gonna be given so I kind of
keep that same mentality now
when did you turn a football or football
find you oh I just I'm gonna play
football baseball and basketball all the
three sports story high school and not
just I was pretty good in out three but
I just knew I had a future in football
after my eleven thirty years so that's
not kind of said with that
so did Spurrier at South Carolina or
Dabo Clemson never knocked on your door
huh you invited me I'll be camping
everything but I mean they didn't pull
the trigger
phone jingling South Carolina portatree
there was a cycle on the state no that's
that's where I was
that's where you went that's where if
I'm not mistaken from what I've read
because I've again I really will enjoy
watching you play and and and and I
wanted to learn as much about you
certainly in advance of our conversation
here Darius Leonard
you took a knee if I'm not mistaken at
the very end of your South Carolina
State career is that a fact okay
describe what I meant by taking a knee
for those who may not understand Darius
home I proposed to my longtime longtime
girlfriend Kayla within been dating
great we've been the same kids going to
class me I knew it was kind of time for
me to drop through me get in there
someday what I love with all my heart so
I know what and your teammates and your
family members were surrounding you
right oh yeah we my teammates her family
my family so I was this person I'm
senior date for me look at you that's a
win-win Darius Leonard that's we call a
win-win so have you set a date yet I
don't want to put any extra pressure on
but oh do we see now that's not a rookie
mistake
see you did it right but you did it in
June that's a smart move where are you
registered you registered somewhere can
we check it out something can we help
you
it'll be a murder Beach okay Carolina
fantastic that's great I'm thrilled to
hear that what's it like watching Andrew
Luck when you have a chance to maybe
stand on that side lon
it's amazing just seeing seeing her
throws that he made just two checks and
maybe pain he's just a great all-around
through than just watching them play
making great plays I'm he's gonna invest
a lot of that's quarterback in the
league and I mean I just loved and I
just admire watching I mean I enjoy
practicing against them everyday kind of
Timmy better with Hill making check
stuff like that so I mean it's great as
a team yeah and whatever what do you
learn from him in terms of being a
professional being a rookie as we've
mentioned many times in this
conversation I see he take care his body
there's no doubt and load of stuff and
how much family watch and the way he has
everything on the skin I just trying to
limit that the way he's come in and in
ourselves make sure he takes a lot of
loss and uh I kind of try to do the same
so I can remember everything is trying
to be like him does he still have a flip
phone or as he got as he last week come
on he does a flip phone come on still
can't believe that now what was it like
for you when you were bawling out early
in the season and as I mentioned at the
top of this conversation you were the
Rookie of the Month Defensive Rookie the
month for September but the winds
weren't coming and you're one in five
well walk me through what that was like
for you coming in knowing knowing that
what kind of team that we had we have a
lot of young guys but we have a lot of
great players and everybody was just
going it all online even if I did have
17 18 out of the game that still wasn't
enough I was still making several
mistakes so I knew what things I had to
get better at so once we once we had a
team two players on the meeting kind of
put everything on the table and
everybody got everything going because I
was in there and and in terms of where
this team can go now that you are six
and five what's the conversation about
in that locker room right now we just we
only take
take another one game at a time and we
hope be one in the left every we that's
how the table can do and goes right I
always talk about being one percent
better each and every day don't try to
do too much I do not unless just be one
percent and be warning lot each week
okay now you take on a Jacksonville team
as you know you're gonna be facing Cody
Kessler there's no Leonard fournette
this is a team that is down they've
fired their offensive coordinator I mean
there's a lot going on in Jacksonville
well what what's your guy's approach
with this one Darius always controlling
the legal control that's of playing and
playing on good sound football long deep
inside of the ball I mean we can say
what what they're gonna do all sensibly
okay we can do is go out and take it one
play at a time I can control illegal
control
alright Darris I mean you're already
you're you know I mean you're rookie but
you're you I think I got to control what
you can control right one game at a time
I mean come on where's where's the
maniac here give me something right you
want to you want to well I mean that's
your nickname he doing what what's the
transformation to become the maniac
competitive nature right now as my
hominis very very humble and ice and so
long that's why I'm off the field in the
meeting rooms anything but was I going
to feel this is maniac mode already you
could compete I want to be the best out
there I'm trying to prove they're the
best out there so that's that's a whole
different side of me I do feel who was
your guy growing up watching Louis right
has he reached out to you because he
reaches out to a ton of people have you
spoken him one day may I make Darius
Leonard may I make that happen for you
I'm serious
I'm absolutely serious we're gonna get
your phone number from the cults and I
will get Ray Lewis on the phone to you
because I believe he would love to talk
to you watching the way you do okay this
would see this is what happens you we
try to make tree dreams come true here
America okay that's the way we roll so
thank you for calling in it and maybe
the next person you'll hear from is Ray
yes sir
I'm gonna make that happen that's Daris
thanks again Congrats on all the all the
accolades you've already received and
keep doing what you're doing yes you got
that's Darius Leonard the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience